SPEAKER: The 2021 State
of DevOps Report released
last year--
it contained findings
about how teams navigate
key areas of software delivery.
We talked to two of the
researchers, Dave Stanke
and Nathen Harvey, about
the report's section on SRE.
Were there any surprising
findings in the report?
DAVE STANKE: I was surprised
to see how widespread SRE
practices are.
It's often been believed
that this is something that's
limited to the Googles
of the world or Facebook,
with their production
engineering discipline, which
is similar to SRE.
What we found is that 52% of
the organizations we studied
are practicing SRE
techniques to some extent.
At the same time, there's
a lot of room for growth.
Among our elite respondents,
only 10% of them
are practicing every reliability
engineering technique
at its fullest.
So everyone has room to grow.
SPEAKER: What did the site
reliability engineering
section of the report focus on?
DAVE STANKE: So this
year, for the first time,
DORA studied Site Reliability
Engineering, or SRE,
and we looked at what practices
are being done among operations
teams in our study and
what kind of outcomes
they're achieving as a result.
NATHEN HARVEY: SRE is Site
Reliability Engineering.
In my mind, it always starts
with that word, reliability.
What does it mean
to be reliable?
At the end of the
day, reliability
is about whether or not your
customers can trust the service
that they're getting
from your applications
or from the services
that you're building.
SPEAKER: What did you
find separates elite teams
from the rest?
DAVE STANKE: So
the best teams are
the ones that are really
treating reliability
as a product feature, as an
aspect of their experience
of what they're
delivering to the user,
and prioritizing it accordingly.
We find that it really helps
to define reliability in terms
of user-facing behavior.
We don't want to look at
how do our machines feel--
do their-- processors
overloaded, are there-- is
there memory fold?
That may be important
operational data.
But it doesn't define
whether our system
is reliable for our users.
So with SRE-- and what
the highest performers do
is they look at it
to say, is our system
delivering on behalf of
what the user is expecting?
Is it serving the user need?
And then we use frameworks,
like the SLO framework,
to operationalize that so that
we can measure in real time
the degree to which we are
keeping up with our promises
to the user.
SPEAKER: How can teams start
implementing these practices?
NATHEN HARVEY: The
best way to apply
these findings is
to first figure out
where are you as a team.
So get your team together.
Get the people that are
responsible for building
the application, for
running the application.
Bring them together in a room.
And together, take the
DORA DevOps quick check.
You'll find that at
cloud.google.com/devops.
With this quick check, you
answer five quick questions
and really help assess how
is my team doing today.
With this information
in hand, you
can then start to look at the
capabilities that are going
to improve that performance.
And of course, we'll
provide some guidance
on what those
capabilities are and where
you should get started
next improving your team.
SPEAKER: What would you say is
the core idea of this section
of the report?
NATHEN HARVEY: The
biggest takeaway
is that you don't have to
trade off speed for stability.
Speed and stability work
hand-in-hand together.
So the most important
thing that you can do
is think about the
users of your service
and make sure that you're
delivering the right value
in a reliable way to them.